he's not in charge he's not calling the
shots the bigger question that people
need to be asking themselves is when
he's not there he's checked out he can't
even make coherent sentences who's
really in charge that's the question
that a lot of people should be asking
themselves can we give a round of
applause to the onion
I love to bring this article up that's
great the stress of presidency already
ages by in 10 years and it shows a
corpse
so so who's in charge if it's not if
it's not Biden who's in charge who's
calling the shots here who's who's at
the desk right now with that button that
could blow the world over 20 times over
it's Ron Clane it's Jake Sullivan it's
definitely not Kamala Victoria Newland
BlackRock and all these other multi
Goldman sacks and all these other
multinational corporations that are
obviously benefiting greatly from the
policies that he's not even putting into
place but he's signing on to and saying
yes I'm for it when in reality I don't
think he's there